[Musique]
un dialogue entre flûte de pan et orgue
sur un opéra d'haendel au coeur de
l'église sainte bernadette de
rambouillet un cadre exceptionnel pour
un duo complémentaire la flûte de pan
c'est l'ancêtre de l'orgue
c'est en y qui s'applique t civile osc a
eu l'idée de réaliser une flûte de pan
beaucoup plus grande que le rappel de
piano orgue
mais c'est depuis l'antiquité donc entre
les flûtes de pan partout à travers le
monde se sont forcément deux instruments
qui se marient très bien puisqu'il ils
vivent sur le même la même énergie à
savoir l'air l'air qui nous fait tous
vivre de jean sébastien bach à erik
satie en passant par la musique
traditionnelle irlandaise
le concert a traversé les époques
he a toujours la file devant à travers
le folklore d'amérique du sud et
d'europe centrale
moi j'ai décidé il ya très longtemps de
cela les dépoussiérer un petit peu cet
instrument qui millénaire en adaptant
justement de la musique classique en
proposant mes musiques
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
concentre tout un talent tout une
approche de la musique qui nous livre
aussi à travers le concert voilà c'est
le s'est réincarné sa façon de faire de
la musique durant l'année 2010 est
georges schmitt sera en tournée dans
différentes églises et cathédrales de
france
il sera à chaque fois accompagnée de
différents musiciens
[Applaudissements]